bonsoir il est 18h si vous nous suivez
en direct comme chaque soir de la
semaine du lundi au vendredi nouvelle
édition du Journal de la rédaction et
voici les titres pour aujourd'hui afin
de débuter au mieux les distributions
alimentaires les associations organisent
des collectes en ce moment dans les
supermarchés c'était le cas ce week-end
dans les Yvelines pour le Secours
populaire préparez les jeunes au monde
du travail objectif de la journée école
entreprise qui vient de se tenir au
lycée villa Roy de Guyancourt et puis 5
millions d'accidents corporels
surviennent chaque année dans les
logements il provoque plus de décès que
ceux de la route la maison des parents
attrape propose une semaine de
prévention le froid est bien présent la
neige pas encore mais les pouvoirs
publics se préparent ainsi le Conseil
général des Yvelines l'ont aujourd'hui
son plan de viabilité hivernale sur les
routes du département jusqu'au 16 mars
122 agents de la Direction des routes et
des transports avons surveiller la météo
et le réseau afin de réagir au plus vite
37 agents sont d'ailleurs en instintre
24 heures sur 24 3800 tonnes de sel sont
stockées sur ensemble des dépôts l'an
dernier 90 interventions seulement
nécessaires l'hiver a été plutôt doux
comme chaque année donc le Secours
populaire des Yvelines se mobilise
l'antenne de Trappes organisé ce
week-end d'une collecte alimentaire dans
un supermarché de Guyancourt toute la
journée les bénévoles se sont relayés
pour réunir les denrées nécessaires pour
les familles qui fréquentent l'antenne
de Trappes Mélanie poquet et Anthony
des flyers comme liste de courses et des
denrées bien précises à collecter de
l'huile du chocolat en poudre les
bénévoles pensent aussi à l'approche de
Noël chez des familles qui ont moins de
10 euros par jour et par personne pour
vivre nous avons un certain nombre de
familles que nous aidons le plus
régulièrement possible on va dire une
fois par mois plus d'une cinquantaine de
familles est concernée sur trappes et la
demande se fait de plus en plus
pressante pour pouvoir les aider une
fois par mois aujourd'hui le chariot se
remplit assez vite c'est naturel je sais
pas depuis que je suis enfant je fais
toujours comme ça et puis voilà c'est
normal on aide le côté plus concret qui
effectivement enfin me plaît pendant le
principe et puis fait ses courses on
prend et puis on a qu'à déposé on n'a
pas voilà ça vient à nous en plus du
coup ça n'aime pas se poser de questions
c'est c'est plus simple quoi un appel
entendu parler client de ce supermarché
la distribution aura lieu à la
mi-décembre
éducation le lycée période déterminant
pour les élèves c'est à ce moment qu'ils
doivent choisir leur orientation
professionnelle afin de les aider sur
cette problématique à Lyon en ce moment
la quinzième édition de la Semaine école
entreprise dans les Yvelines dans ce
cadre différents initiatives différentes
rencontres organisées comme des visites
d'entreprises ou encore des
présentations de métiers d'avenir au
lycée de Villarois c'est l'apprentissage
qui est mis en avant par le CFA de
l'orrosoir à Guyancourt Florane parfait
et le dimanche
l'apprentissage ses élèves en ont très
peu entendu parler ils sont en première
générale au lycée Villaroy Guyancourt et
cette filière ne fait pas partie de leur
priorité post-baccalauréat c'est
pourquoi l'institut de formation par
alternance de leurs rosoir présente ses
bts domotique numérique ou électrique au
lycée 1 ça a l'air intéressant à faire
ça doit être une bonne expérience
j'imagine mais j'ai pas trop envie de
faire ça je pensais faire une prépa
Mathieu Maths Spé une école d'ingénieurs
oui ça m'a intéressé mais aussi j'avais
déjà c'est ce que je vais faire plus
tard c'est bien de savoir
d'autres filières possibles qu'on peut
faire dans le cadre de la Semaine école
entreprise un des enjeux est de
valoriser les formations à caractère
professionnel alifa de le roswa plus de
80% des jeunes en alternance ou en
apprentissage sortent diplômés et près
de 90% trouve un emploi à la fin de leur
cursus si ces formations ont du mal à
séduire elles ont pourtant des arguments
poursuivre dans le traditionnel mais
dans un an ils vont commencer à
réfléchir sur l'alternance ce que c'est
la rémunération les avantages et les
inconvénients de chacun des deux côtés
que ce soit de l'apprentissage ou du
traditionnel on est encore avec des
mentalités qui pensent que
l'apprentissage n'est pas une formule
intéressante et où on envoie en fait les
personnes qui n'ont pas des niveaux
intéressants c'est faux puisqu'on a
quand même des partenariats avec les
universités partenariat avec de grandes
écoles ou des écoles d'ingénieurs donc
on n'en voit pas quand même des jeunes
qui n'ont pas de niveau sur ces sur ces
formations l'alternance et
l'apprentissage des moyens de rapprocher
un peu plus les élèves du monde de
l'entreprise l'année dernière plus de
800 jeunes et enseignants c'était
inscrits ou aux rencontres école
entreprises ils sont 1900 cette année
éducation emploi toujours avec ce forum
de la réussite proposée à Manille et un
mot ce samedi des ateliers pour
présenter différents métiers des séances
pour aiguiller les jeunes présents leur
apprendre à réaliser des lettres de
motivation ou encore des CV par exemple
un forum presque comme les autres sauf
qu'il était organisé ce n'est pas
courant par des élus de l'opposition de
Magny-les-Hameaux une promesse de
campagne explique Aurore berger
c'est absolument pas un forum militant
on l'organise nous ça a été monté à
titre bénévole par des membres de
l'équipe des gens qui sont spécialistes
des questions de ressources humaines
notamment moi ma motivation et
vraiment beaucoup autour des jeunes et
pour les aider avec les compétences que
l'on peut mettre en place autour de ça
et pour eux après je suis contente que
ça se passe dans le cadre de Manille
nouvelle énergie mais si ça s'était
passé dans un cadre hors politique je
pense que j'aurais mis la même énergie
comme j'ai un rendez-vous lundi à l'AFPA
je me suis dit que c'était un bon
entraînement un petit peu avant
cet entretien mon CV je vais sûrement le
refaire le retravailler avec les
conseils qui m'ont donné je pense que je
serai sûrement prêt pour lundi l'équipe
de manie énergie qui souhaite organiser
d'autres rendez-vous de ce type
également des conférences sur des sujets
sur Aurore berger qui ne seront pas
politiques et politique justement
Valérie Pécresse juge que l'abrogation
de la loi sur le mariage homosexuel
n'est pas humainement réaliste la
députée des Yvelines année au moins
estimé que la loi devait être réécrite
sur les questions de filiation et que
des écrous forts devaient encadrer la
gestation et la procréation pour autrui
une déclaration qui fait suite aux
propos de Nicolas Sarkozy lors d'un
meeting il a déclaré ce week-end vouloir
abroger la loi Taubira Valérie Pécresse
qui maintient son soutien Nicolas
Sarkozy pour devenir le Président de
l'UMP le 29 novembre mais qui se
démarque donc sur ce sujet celles qui
dirige la formation dans les Yvelines
par ailleurs affirmé que c'est Bruno Le
Maire qui incarnait le renouveau
on laisse la politique de côté pour
s'intéresser aux accidents domestiques
il y en aurait chaque année à 5 millions
près de la moitié des visites près de la
moitié de ses accidents se traduisent
par des visites aux urgences et parfois
par des décès un peu plus de 10000 les
jeunes enfants les personnes âgées elles
sont les premières victimes et alors que
s'ouvre attrap une semaine de son
civilisation nous sommes allés à votre
rencontre pour entendre vos témoignages
tout simplement avec la cuisine et en
particulier avec les genres cocottes
minutes et autres pour les enfants je
dirais l'absorption de produits ménagers
les gamins qui se font tomber dessus
l'eau chaude ou de l'eau bouillante pour
les enfants peut-être les problèmes de
cuisinière personne âgées bah c'est
plutôt les je pense plutôt les chutes
avec les enfants c'est à l'accès aux
médicaments ou produits ménagers
au niveau de la salle de bain
les glissades
et dans le cadre de la semaine de
sensibilisation qui s'ouvre donc à
attrape il y a un appartement en
pédagogique qui a été présenté
aujourd'hui l'une de nos équipes était
présente reportage de Mélanie poquet
ça s'appelle narratoire c'est une espèce
de petite chaîne qu'on accroche de
chaque côté des battants de la fenêtre
et le gamin il peut pas le décrocher
votre fenêtre va s'ouvrira pas plus que
ça
sert à repasser qui refroidit meuble
trop proche des fenêtres ou encore
téléphone qui sonne à l'heure du bain
des enfants toutes ces situations de la
vie quotidienne peuvent se révéler être
un danger pour les accidents de la vie
courante c'est le sphère la sphère
privée et du coup on en parle un petit
peu moins ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
en France on est à 11 millions de
blessés par an plus ou moins graves et
19000 morts 50% des accidents de la vie
quotidienne ont lieu dans la maison à
cause de chutes de brûlures ou de noyade
alors cette vingtaine de femmes la
plupart mère de famille est attentive
car né à la main elle ne perdent pas une
miette des conseils de Daniel tronche
diffusé dans le cadre de la Semaine de
prévention à Trappes avant de visiter
cet appartement pédagogique pour y
déceler les erreurs à ne pas commettre
j'ai pris beaucoup de choses pour le
danger pour tout ça pour la cuisine pour
les enfants faut pas laisser traîner les
prises par terre portant pour la
sécurité de la maison pour les enfants
pour les grands personnes aussi on a un
massage chez nous on a besoin pour
savoir de plus en plus si l'on pense
souvent aux enfants comme victime les
adultes sont aussi concernés et
principalement les personnes de 75 ans
et plus sont pour autant voir du danger
partout le principe c'est de prévenir
pour que la maison reste un lieu
accueillant
les avocats en grève demain et mercredi
à travers la France le Barreau de
Versailles a décidé ce matin en
assemblée générale de rejoindre ce
mouvement nous sommes en ligne avec le
bâtonnier Frédéric Landon bonsoir
bonsoir votre contestation qui porte sur
plusieurs projets de loi du gouvernement
globalement on peut aussi dire que c'est
la peur de la perte de votre
indépendance qui vous inquiète il existe
un projet actuellement de réforme et qui
autoriserait l'ouverture du capital des
cabinets d'avocats aux entreprises c'est
ça le point qui vous inquiète le plus
aujourd'hui alors
sont insérés dans ce qu'on appelle le
projet de loi Macron qui est un projet
de loi qui a été élaboré sans aucune
concertation d'avocat et qui a nos yeux
est une escroquerie intellectuelle
puisqu'on essaye de faire croire que les
mesures envisagées permettraient de
redonner du pouvoir d'achat à nos
concitoyens alors il y a quatre points
qui posent difficultés d'abord c'est ce
qu'on appelle la suppression de la
territorialité de la postulation ça veut
dire pour parler simplement d'avoir
recours auprès d'un avocat du cru par
exemple à Versailles d'avoir recours un
avocat du barreau de Versailles pour
certaines procédures si c'est remis en
cause ça va créer ce qu'on appelle des
déserts judiciaires un peu partout en
France et il n'y aura plus de proximité
pour les concitoyens donc de avoir
recours à des avocats du cru qui
pourront répondre à leur demande la
deuxième deuxième point c'est la
création d'un statut d'avocat salariés
en entreprise qui est pour nous
totalement impossible puisque c'est
contraire aux principes d'indépendance
de notre profession un avocat salarié
est un entrepreneur ne peut pas être
indépendant dans sa mission et troisième
point que vous avez déjà évoqué c'est
l'ouverture capital des sociétés locales
et capitaux extérieurs donc c'est à dire
que ça peut être des financier des
assureurs des banquiers je ne sais qui
et là c'est une remise en cause
l'importance de l'avocat puisque il
dépendrait de la volonté de ceux qui
détiendraient de ces capitaux donc tous
ces éléments-là sont que les avocats
sont en grève le Barreau de Versailles a
rejoint ce mouvement et dès la semaine
dernière et nous serons donc en Grèce
totale mardi et mercredi prochain et
pour la première fois de notre histoire
nous assurons pas les missions de
service public notamment liés à la
Convention contentieux la détention donc
il n'y aura strictement aucun avocat à
l'audience donc il n'y aura pas de
justice les mardis et mercredi prochain
voir au Père Noël on revient sur les
différentes revendications que vous avez
les différents points que vous avez
exposé tout à l'heure je m'attarde juste
une fois de plus sur cette question de
de réforme et de l'ouverture du capital
des cabinets ça veut dire que ce que
vous craignez comme d'autres de votre
collègue qui l'ont déjà exprimé c'est
que aujourd'hui on soit après si cette
réforme passait plus dans une recherche
de de profit que le système judiciaire
cède aux sirènes de la finance c'est ce
qu'on entend par les avocats
économique comme une autre alors que
l'avocat n'est pas un acteur économique
comme comme un autre c'est un profession
libérale et indépendante et qui
notamment assure des missions de service
public et nous sommes une profession
libérale indépendante et l'indépendance
est quelque chose de très important nous
avons donc la maîtrise sur la structure
de nos cabinets c'est nous qui en
décidons et si nous ne dette non plus
les rennes financières et bien l'avocat
ne sera plus du tout indépendant je
voudrais simplement rebondir on nous
fait le reproche d'être une profession
archaïque c'est une contre-vérité il n'y
a pas une profession réglementée qui se
soit autant modernisée en 10 ans nous
sommes totalement adaptés à la loi du
marché nous sommes ouverts nous sommes
pas une proposition qui est fermée
puisque nous sommes tout à fait ouvert à
la concurrence je vous rappelle qu'il y
a deux conditions pour devenir avocat
faut avoir un diplôme et des conditions
de moralité il n'y a strictement aucun
numéro de Claus autre difficulté c'est
qu'en remettant en cause le recours à
l'avocat auprès du tribunal en question
ça va remettre en cause la solid le
cabinet sur le plan économique mais
aussi l'existence pelle des ordres et
une considérons qu'il n'y a pas d'avocat
efficace indépendant et libre s'il n'est
pas adossé à un ordre local voilà tout
ce qui fait que nous sommes tout à fait
en colère et une fois de plus ni
supportons pas le mépris avec lequel les
pouvoirs publics traitent puisque ce
projet de loi de Macron dont on parle et
bien n'a jamais fait l'objet d'une
concertation et notamment il n'y a pas
eu du tout l'étude d'impact par rapport
aux mesures qui sont envisagées donc
faut comprendre que lorsque les avocats
cessent de travailleurs ces conditions
c'est que c'est vraiment des conditions
parce qu'il y a une exigence importante
et quelle revendication est-ce que nous
menons comme combat c'est avant tout un
combat dans l'intérêt de nos concitoyens
bien sûr pour nous parce qu'on souhaite
continuer ce métier mais c'est un métier
qui n'a pas de clients sens qui est sans
intérêt donc c'est pour nos concitoyens
que nous menons ce combat et il se
terminera en fin de semaine par un très
grand rassemblement à Versailles au
départ se rassemblement de vais
regrouper simplement les avocats des
barons du ressort c'est à dire Chartres
Pontoise les Hauts-de-Seine et
Versailles mais le baron d'huile de
France souhaite venir à Versailles
vendredi prochain matin donc je pense
qu'il y aura très grand nombre d'avocats
à Versailles pour manifester leur
mécontentement et notre objectif pour
clore mon propos c'est premièrement
d'obtenir le retrait du projet Macron on
ne peut pas légiférer dans les
conditions pareilles et deuxièmement
imposer au pouvoir public de bien
vouloir discuter d'une vraie réforme
d'aide juridictionnelle c'est un projet
qui nous attendons depuis plus de 15 ans
et malheureusement les pouvoirs publics
ne respectent pas leurs paroles une
dernière question néanmoins avant de
clore votre propos concernant et vous
l'avez dit en préambule cette volonté du
gouvernement de rendre la justice plus
accessible c'est l'argument qui est
avancé en diminuant les coûts vous
parlez de l'aide juridictionnelle
notamment sur son financement
aujourd'hui il y a des réformes à faire
quels sont vos propositions
elles sont très claires notamment sur le
fonctionnement de la justice on est prêt
à participer avec justice du 21e siècle
on nous a fait travailler en début
d'année sur le chantier ouvert pendant
ce Mirande a fait plein de propositions
pendant à l'amélioration des photos de
justice notamment sur des voies qui
permettent d'éviter un contentieux la
médiation des choses comme ça des
propositions ont été faites on a proposé
notamment ce qu'on appelle l'accusation
juridique est un acte d'avocats qui
permettrait de procédures donc toutes
ces propositions ont été faites elle a
ça on n'a rien retenu puisque le
chantier de la justice du 21e siècle
n'aboutira rien il faut pas croire qu'on
peut améliorer la justice sans
financement et en réalité l'État ne veut
pas mettre d'argent et ont été on est en
train de d'administrer la misère de la
justice et on essaye d'imposer aux
avocats et bien de supporter cette
misère donc voilà vous en sommes et
c'est un état catastrophique de la
justice dans ce pays et on ne peut pas
accepter ce qui se passe et je crois que
les pouvoirs publics doivent entendre
les messages parce que on va pas
s'arrêter simplement des manifestations
on va aller jusqu'à l'épreuve de force
avec quand vous avez 36000 avocats en
France c'est-à-dire tous les avocats de
province qui permet de travailler
pendant une semaine qui vont manifester
c'est que vraiment le temps est très
très important pour nous et pour nos
concitoyens et je crois que il
appartient au public d'entendre le
message on est prêt à discuter sur un
certain nombre de sujets mais il y a des
propositions qui sont totalement
inacceptables il faut pas croire qu'on
sera fonctionner un moment la justice si
on ne donne pas l'argent suffisant non
pour ce budget linguistique avant la
juridictionnelle je vais pas vous
indiquer que les classements de la
France au plan européen mais c'est une
véritable catastrophe par rapport à
d'autres pays comme l'état français
c'est-à-dire les États démocratiques
merci Frédéric Landon d'avoir été en
ligne avec nous bâtonniers de Versailles
les avocats en grève mardi mercredi et
puis cette mobilisation vous l'aurez
rappeler vendredi matin à Versailles
merci à vous
nous passons au sport à présent dans
cette édition du journal en ce lundi
avant de retrouver juste après ce
journal Le 7 8 sport avec Anthony Reich
vous allez découvrir à présent un raid
100% féminin le raid Amazon la 13e
édition se déroule jusqu'au 25 novembre
au Cambodge des Yvelines relève ceux et
défis et c'est loin d'être de tout repos
reportage
habituer des rallyes voitures
Anne-Sophie avait fait le tour du volant
désireuse d'atteindre ses limites il y a
un an et demi elle s'inscrit au raid
Amazon une compétition 100% féminine où
les équipes enchaînent pendant plusieurs
jours des épreuves de canoë VTT et de
course à pied ce point de rupture
psychologique cette directrice de
marketing latin lors de l'épreuve de
trek je ne me souviens de rien n'a
absolument rien de cette règle j'ai
couru pendant 15 km en me souvenant de
rien je ne sais pas si je courais sur de
la terre sur du bitume apparemment j'ai
fait un peu de tout je me souviens de
rien je me souviens du bout de mes
chaussures le noir complet je suis tombé
après l'arche et l'arrivée je me
souviens être allé voir l'organisatrice
en lui disant mais l'année prochaine si
je t'appelle pour te dire que je veux
m'inscrire surtout tu m'interdis de
m'inscrire je ne veux plus jamais vivre
ça
en me disant non seulement tu vas me
rappeler mais en plus tu vas te inscrire
résultat ces bagages sont déjà prêtes
pour cette 13e édition et avec deux
traits au programme un joli pied de nez
pour cette sportive qui n'avait jamais
fait de footing jusqu'à il y a un an et
demi mais le raid n'est pas seulement un
défi physique c'est aussi une aventure
humaine qui vous transforme à 42 ans
Anne-Sophie participe à son deuxième
raid marqué par une première épopée
inoubliable il faut aimer ses ambiances
il faut aimer les défis il faut aimer
avoir envie de se dépasser il faut aimer
avoir envie de se prouver je pense qu'on
a toutes celles qui participent en fait
on a quelque chose à se prouver c'est
une bulle également c'est moi le raid
c'est le seul moment où je suis
Anne-Sophie je suis pas maman je suis
pas madame je redeviens juste
Anne-Sophie après la Malaisie en 2013
Anne-Sophie va découvrir le Cambodge
mais l'île-vinoise ne part pas pour
faire du tourisme son équipe compte bien
terminer parmi les 40 meilleurs
habitué une dernière information pour
finir ce journal à La Verrière samedi à
un cambrioleur a blessé à l'arme blanche
le propriétaire d'un pavillon surpris
par le propriétaire des lieux il l'a
blessé de deux coups de couteau au
visage et au thorax le pronostic vital
elle n'est pas engagée je vous retrouve
Mardi 18h pour un nouveau journal
toujours en direct pour cette première
édition excellente soirée